nouveau numéro de reporter le dock le
magazine de reportages long format de
france 24 aujourd'hui nous vous
proposons de suivre le parcours
incroyable d'un jeune humoriste africain
invité pour la première fois de sa vie à
se produire en spectacle sur la scène du
plus prestigieux festivals d'humour
celui de montreux en suisse
là où se succèdent les stars de l'humour
francophone clan télex c'est son nom à
23 ans il habite dans le quartier pauvre
d'abobo à abidjan plutôt que de céder à
la violence ambiante il a préféré manier
larmes de l'humour et grâce à son talent
c'est lui qui a remporté le concours
organisé en côte d' ivoire d'abidjan à
montreux clan télex va faire le plus
grand voyage de sa vie découvrir la
réalité d'un monde qu'il a fantasmé
j'irai faire rire les blancs c'est un
documentaire de noémie mayodon et jean
charles richard
[Musique]
mais là messieurs non mais dans des côte
d'ivoire voiçi condé lès belles balades
ou bamba d'ambam
bonsoir
je suis plein télex et je vienne abobo
ouais abobo c'est en côte d'ivoire quand
tu prends aujourd'hui ce dont je veux
que sur la scène tu t'éclates donc quand
tu bonjour de clan de l'ex soit tu
arrives bonjour comment allez vous
pour ce qu'il fait froid ici toi tu
viens pas bonjour je suis content avec
ça ça prouve à la fois ça prouve qu'ils
étaient vénérées ouais ouais ouais moi
je suis convaincu que dans un premier
temps avoir une interaction avec le
public si le premier contact la toule
euros ici tu caches tout un spectacle
donc expressions de visage il ce froid
mais tu es content d'être là mine de
rien maintenant après tu peux revenir
finnair et plus commencer son petit on
peut c'est sain
mesdames messieurs en provenance de côte
d'ivoire le jeune et talentueux comptez
vous à
vous je crois en fait mais ça va ça va
ça va aller voilà je suis que le télex
et je viens d'un robot voilà deux on va
y arriver en fait avant de venise a eu
le temps de regarder cette vidéo du
festival sur youtube et leur emad qui
viennent le plus souvent c'est que le
public de montereau est très timide pour
pêcher une pâture
enfin c'est sûr que quand sûrs quand
l'argent curie - ouais donc c'est ça
irrite paille c'est pas forcément très
loquace parce qu'ils ont trop d'argent
c'est quand même la suisse tu vois il
peine à l'aise flatte les dealers qu'ils
ont beaucoup d'argent aura une cale ou
en afrique on rit pour tous on a fait
courir fort on rit parce qu'on n'est pas
sûr de rires après donc on rira
bon donc je compte sur vous ce soir pour
qu'on rit comme en afrique parce que moi
je suis venu pour faire il est blanc
on a trouvé le truc au web
j'étais vu cent fois sur scène je sais
que je t'éclate
oublie long je lui le fait que ouais je
viens jouer contre eux il ya des choses
à démontrer
quand arrive la salle unique déjà été
bon
c'est déjà bon
[Musique]
arrière ton esprit fin de dix ans je
suis celui qui a tombe dessus alors si
la scène qui ont reçu les agents elle
c'est toi le boss
ça ça te donne ça te donne tu veux
l'assurance de faire des choses en
beauce ont dû à un moment tu es dur
[Musique]
et platoir fassi libère-toi une histoire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en fait on est dans la cour où j'ai
grandi en fait c'est la poudre de mon
enfant c'est ici que je suis ni c'est
ici que j'ai grandi tout ça et c'est ici
même que je commençais à fait l'humour
on va dire ça comme ça et là c'est le
moment de mon ami etienne etienne en
fait on était ensemble tout petit il est
là etienne
ici je suis chez moi en fait je suis
chez moi je me retrouve comme je décoche
des petits tout ça il y avait pas si
nous on lave les habits à tous la
cuisine qu'on ne on a tous la douche
entre nous on prête au passage un peu
tout à part peut-être la prochaine
surtout reportage
les disputes et le bonheur on fait
innocent
le mur le plus pire on va dire comme un
mariage
ap
en côte d'ivoire quand on dit ah vous
c'est la violence c'est le vent c'est
les pauvres qui vivent en fait et quand
arrive pas à voir ce que tu veux de boue
tous deux dit une industrie soit tu
passes par la violence mais ça ne change
rien nous soit du coup moi j'ai décidé
de passer par jour
[Musique]
c'est
parce qu'on voit danser comme un gland
l'encensoir meda précieux
de la danse façon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dont je vous parlais au moins un enfant
c'est que d'acheter de procès ni soumis
à des concerts et monsieur jeu
blanc bavures
dont on a toujours parlé mais je n'ai
jamais eu la chance de rencontrer
et je sais que cela c'est le cas de la
majorité des besoins ici le big one
way juste on nous dit que le père noël
passe dans la cheminée les cadeaux de
noël
mais si nous avons dans nos maisons
n'ont jamais autant même petit corps
va passer
de venir déposer les cadeaux 100 g parce
que moi même bien y avait mon vélo à
[Musique]
l'appui ils vont tuer les jeunes les
cadres ont pu voler le principe pendant
un mois
bon du coup non à ça mais vu le pen de
l'arbre bon j'ai pas il n'existe pas là
samedi à
[Applaudissements]
abidjan vivre les jeudi 21 et vendredi
22 mars prochain au rythme du premier
festival du moins francophones du nommé
africa comedy
moi je suis convaincu que le mot peut
changer les mots
on a quand même ont sélectionné une
trentaine de personnes pour faire un
concours jeunes talents ici point
l'afrique les gens disent comédie
qu'armstrong donc la comédie vient de la
douleur la souffrance quelques pas
[Musique]
on
le concours jeunes talents c'est une
sélection donc on va trouver quelqu'un
qui va passer à montreux et qui va
vraiment marché
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ok ce qu'on a tout le monde ou pas allez
venez venez par là s'il vous plaît je
connais par la tiens on va se mettre de
voir abidjan allez on est venu chercher
un artiste africain est unique par
rapport à son africanité son parcours
par rapport à ce regard sur le monde
qu'on a envie aussi de donner même si ça
peut être local où ça peut être encore
aujourd'hui quelque chose qui est avant
tout africain mais qui est universel il
nous semble que ce soir il ya un artiste
qui réunit ces trois critères et c'est
lui qu'on va choisir et donc c'est qu'il
tenait qu
[Applaudissements]
est ce qui est intéressant c'est
l'universalité ton histoire ce que l'on
pense qu'en travaillant ton texte on
travaille encore ton débit et ton jeu
d'acteur ton histoire qui lui remet en
africaine et qui est très propre à toi
même si quelqu'un n'est jamais allé en
afrique caen - allez abobo que tu peux
partager cette histoire là et emmener
les gens avec toi il faut trouver ton
fric il faut trouver ton flow trouver
encore tes mots mais tu as tout ce qu'il
faut pour le faire donc on va bosser et
puis tu vas venir à montreux avec nous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous
oui
[Musique]
c'est me voie sacrée
en laboratoire
[Musique]
c'est ici que je viens et crée je viens
répéter mes thèses ne venu connu quoi
j'ai fini et je mourrai
[Musique]
avec le vent avec le calme
qu'avant une inspiration paris par
exemple qui sont en plus ces pratiques
m
[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir bonsoir bonsoir
je suis qu un télex je viens des
quartiers d'abidjan où c'est toujours
pas la fête quoi c'est abobo
hui à burgos et katia où il ya pas mal
de braquage pas mal de viol la violence
le sous-développement 01 fera tuer ici
les nas et mal entretenu si c'était du
cinéma
salle est un mélange de la cité des
dieux et massacre à la tronçonneuse
voilà vous voyez maintenant à quoi
ressemble à gogo voilà c'est dans ce
climat qui paraît peut-être instable
pour vous mais tout à fait convenable
pour moi que j'ai fait tout mon enfance
[Musique]
souvenirs avec maman
mamette moi comme j'avais qu'elle ségou
librairie c'est quand on paye en fait de
gadi le prix elle discute ça marche
n'a pas le temps a fait et fait chaud
moi
lausanne je me devais d'être maître les
pantalons ici tout est frais
et
ouais dans la vallée ont déjà les dents
et mie2i s'y attend
pas sur le
respect c'est grisant un visage connu
non je ne connais pas le visage ce soir
il faut l'écarter non on n'a pas pas
comme sarah reprendra en commande 195
et tourner ça comme ça
las elle visera c'est le visa des jeux
de table et ouais le pasp ont le
passeport
7h03 histoires bizarres au soir là et
puis on en a le mérite d'avoir tu
comprends qu'on vend sa division
le président le passeport tu as vu seul
objet que la coop sa as maintenant
voici visas visent et bien que tu vas
longue et vise à aider les travées
nombre au quai maintenant visa là
et puis les deux soldats le savoir d'un
pincement au kiel environ les bruits
mais ça va mon père aimait
moi
[Musique]
où
tu vois moi la neige et reynaldo 6e
saison
la neige
je vois la peine
comment l'as tu es belle
[Musique]
oh
moi je me dis l'europe c'est pareil tu
vois moi il me voit plutôt dans la salle
où tu vas loin de jouer dans les loges
que soit doublons l'espèce voir l'espèce
tu vois là de na li na sur les
spectacles vont aussi la patrie
mais si c'est tout moi c'était contre
l'express et beaucoup de membres sans
enfant
[Musique]
j'ai pas connu mon pays elle la joue le
rôle du et du père et de la mère
on est lié bah ouais c'est bien beau ni
fabien bois sur leur propre équipe les
balles et abanda a notamment asséné
qu'asmara soumis nous fait me rendre à
boissy qui a été mieux pour franklin
morales je démens le saint-esprit d'être
présent dans l'avion
tout ce qu il a appelé à défier à
l'effet là-bas et dieu même le béni que
dieu même le dirigeant frais avec des
frères madiot lié à tout voir mais c'est
un roman
mémoires bien pour l'avoir
[Musique]
je veux lui rendre tout cela faisant
maman jours
[Musique]
bon voyage à vous merci mme obama en
voyage
il tu déchire tu déchire je vais essayer
d'appliquer tous de gauche doit et si tu
peux pas l'âge pour amuse-toi moustoir
us toi ô asie dis toi que je vais pour
m'amuser que la chance d'avoir des
vacances gouin ouest est l'un des rares
voix des vacances en suisse dont on m'a
dit tu t'amuses prenez là on te regarde
son soutien au peuple est d'accord là
c'est beaucoup
en apparence la baule
ben
[Musique]
oh
on pense pas ou là
et les surtensions 6 août elle est
parfois dépassée
705 vous aidez vos frères jumeaux des
classes il
[Musique]
voir ça
bonjour
je suis content les
bernois
déjà au pouvoir ouais moi aussi go
voyages pas ouais ouais ouais
est-ce que vous êtes prêts à partir
quelque chose sinon ça va ben ouais je
n'ai de la voiture parquée juste là une
juste que je valide le ticket à pau doit
ressortir que j'allais d'accord et les
ducs qui s'est maquillée donne mais je
sais pas j'ai vécu ça marche tu mens
pour la traîne pour va ouais
mais en fait ici c'est pas content parce
qu'ils ont dit et il fait froid ici
aujourd'hui sarah a
heidi moi je connaissais dimanche que je
joue dix mois sous dimanche ouais j'ai
vu que le matin il ya très peu de
ménages belges
s'y fait assez chaud fait pas
d'accord
[Musique]
et
il est 8h 50
[Musique]
on fait un rectangle -
mais bonjour tout le monde
[Musique]
content de vous voir vous savez que donc
on est une délégation qui arrivent au
canada du québec de montréal plus
précisément des rues
7e étage et bref on arrive avec notre
petit bagage de connaissances dans
l'enseignement de l'humour parce que
c'est ce qu'on fait à l'école nationale
de l'humour depuis trente deux ans et
dans nos voulait faire un petit tour de
table pour commencer oui ben juste pour
apprendre à connaître tout le monde tu
te monde puisse se présenter rapidement
dont un peu votre votre profil ce que
vous avez fait vous en êtes où j'ai fait
un bac s une prépa lettres une école de
commerce je prends un peu et après
l'école je me suis lancé dans l'humour
donc il ya cinq ans et je joue vraiment
depuis quatre aujourd'hui je me suis
intermittent du spectacle comme on dit
en france et je fais 80 cents dates par
an à peu près avec le spectacle un peu
partout dans tous les cafés de france et
de navarre j'ai un spectacle qui tourne
quand même à une allure a beaucoup moins
rapide que la tienne
je fais une erreur pour 5 10 vingtaine
de dates par an et puis tous les
plateaux puis je crie black quoi
mais ça fait trois ans que je fais du
moci jeu contre les deux ans de l'école
paquet cette année c'est ma première
année dans les bars à montréal et autour
du dividende et les alentours dans le
québec dans le prologue ma première
vraie annie de stand-up stade
je vais commencer par le par le théâtre
quand j'avais 15 ans et après à la fin
du lycée en suisse on va faire un
travail de fin d'études et j'ai fait un
one man show en fait et c'est comme ça
que j'ai commencé d'humour je
connaissais absolument rien du tout chà
pas qu'il fallait d'abord faire des cinq
minutes et dix minutes jouées du coup
j'ai fait direct une heure une heure et
quart
bah moi s'est plaint de l'ex j'ai 23 ans
je viens de la poudre du vin précisément
à beaucoup à commencer le monde on va
dire ce musulman yacine
et j'ai une licence au théâtre
maintenant je suis en 4ème année du
théâtre c'est ma première fois l'équipe
du mont pis
c'est tout je fais des vidéos sur les
réseaux sociaux pour essayer de faire
rire les gens on voit peut-être pour moi
on a quand même un programme chargé
alors vous ramassez on voulait quand
même jeté des bases petit lexique daniel
dessus non ces quelques mots clés parce
que son qu'on ait le même langage pour
pour qu'on se comprenne donc toujours la
mise en situation le set up font de
cette noble du terme anglais donc la
mise en situation dans tous les débuts
de la blague ce qui nous donne les
informations qu'on a besoin de savoir ce
qui me donne les clés dont claire le set
up ou la mise en situation ensuite la
prémisse qui est le début du procès des
comics et qu'on commence à étirer
l'élastique
et puis le punch c'est quand on lâche
vous dites la chute je pense france donc
non disent pourtant le terme show
consensus plutôt le thème punch parce
qu'un pancha frappe alors qu'une chose
ça tombe à bouloc
tu veux y aller je le sentais chanter
ton énergie était en train de
oui je sentais une bouillie d'accord
nous sommes prêts à faire une
présentation aux messieurs voici quand
alex
bonjour bonjour je viens de la côte du
voyage au cycle un télex et ici ça
caille
ouais bon avant de venise a eu le temps
de regarder quelques vidéos des éditions
précédentes du festival sur youtube et
la remarque devient le plus souvent
c'est que le puck de montreux est très
timide alors que nous habitants n'a reçu
le festival et j'ai pu voir sur youtube
aussi le commentaire qui disait que le
public était génial tu as lu au moins
s'est lâché mais on ne peut pas vous
rajouter la pierre il ya des preuves et
s'est pas expliqué en cela aurait plus
forts en afrique ainsi parce que là bas
on n'est pas sûr de riz plus tard donc
sur le moment tout ou alors que vous ça
va
vous devez connaître encore de bons
moments
on m'a dit tu viens jouer en suisse à
montreux même pas en antarctique quoi il
fait trop froid il est tellement il
faisait froid je présume habite alors
que certaines de vos croyances ont tout
à fait fondés quoi c'est pas évident que
je puisse la peine mais je les ai vus
quand même et puis j'ai pas envie de
rester ici bon ben si vous le visa tout
ça mais je préfère moi un bobo et s'il
ya des gens qui venait avec moi
découvrir mon quartier d'enfance bon
allez je vous paye le voyage c'est
gratuit prenez ce numéro là allez prenez
7,970 sans eux il s'appelle mamadou il
habite à toulon il a une petite
embarcation très sympa il a l'habitude
de faire le voyage à vide ce qui va vous
faire un bon prix allez je vous attends
abobo à très bientôt même si c'était moi
80 merci
vous c'est parfait
ça caille ça veut dire qu'est ce que ça
veut dire ça te
permet de critiquer d'acheter ici puis
de
critiquer la suisse puisse jeu super
sympathique je me questionne on se met
en tête au début je me questionnais
quand tu attaques le public ce qui est
très très risqué à faire en général de
dire en public qu'il est pas un bon
public le sait vraiment risqué
je le dis en marche bien ensuite mais je
le demande même si c'est
si on doit cibler aussi précis que le
public de montreux qui est timide c'est
peut-être le public suisse souper télé
publique je sais pas c'est peut-être
c'est moins raide sûr que leur dire que
le public de ce festival ici que ton
éviter son froid tu sais c'est que c'est
injuste c'est un jeu dangereux mais
peut-être que dire j'avais entendu que
public suisse c'est le jeu plus générale
c'est moins ciblés étaient fois par
rapport au public africain puis l'a
peut-être toute comparaison entre la
suisse l'afrique fonctionne super bien
fait que peut-être il faut nettoyer
d'adoucir un plus bas en même temps je
vais pas affecter l'efficacité suis
parce que ça marche bien
chaque artiste savage chaque artiste se
concentrer avant sa prestation puis on a
la chance en suisse je veux dire trop
fort - 68 ce que peut laisser les loges
ouverte il ya personne qui vient tous
les trucs donc ça c'est cool
voilà
donc maintenant elle à la salle on va
les voir cette salle mythique magique
et pour l'artiste
attention
en france on les a mis le souk en solex
avec moi ouais belle salle il montre
comment le public
ah et la salle et voilà le décor de
montreux avec écrit montreux
om
ça va c'est beau c'est un bel outil un
beau joueur en plus
dimanche s'est plaint donc
et puis c'est le public dimanche deux
jeunes on sortir s'amuser rigoler
tu as en valais sur scène en fait bien
voir ça
ils m'entendre c'est bon
camille a refusé
si
les sources et le prophète à wikong à 1
c'est lui en fait c'est un autre monde
dans sa main droite
quand tu viendras sur scène tu auras ta
lumière mais tout et après tu as plus
qu'à fin juin ouais tu joues pour les
gens du premier rang et puis si tu joues
comme si avec 2010 et c'est un jeu un
ouais mais c'est vrai que ça je ne
voudrais pas que ça sur les derniers
mots trop
bon paquet coûte moins cher y aller
bonne chance ce moment dit merde c'est
que chez nous on dit merde ouais ouais
c'est ça ouais je sais pourquoi on
demand puis c'est beaucoup de terre dont
nous avait dit que avancé que la bougie
qui m'atterre au théâtre et quand il est
à ce prix pat est invaincu le chemin et
casillas est de mettre sur la scène
c'est qu'il ya assez de monde aux faits
d'autres contrats je te souhaite à céder
m exactement parfaite c'est cool et
simon bah merde alors
d'accord
oui télex donc
qu'à hervier avec six trous froid pour
hyper hyper de son intérêt puis tourne
pas une généralité le dire par là c'est
pour
je trouve pas que ça va dans le sens de
ce qui veut dire parce que c'est quoi le
sujet de son truc
c'est quand il dit quand même au bout du
compte qu'il aime son pays qui aime
dhouibi maury et ils disent pas qu'il
veut me grey allons au contraire il
compterait que je amener les gens faut
que ce soit ce fil rouge l'offre fou que
soit l'heure de digues des déceptions
comme le père noël
mais que finalement quand il compare
avec l'europe les règlements puis tout
ça est mieux chez lui le thé vous
devriez venir d'ailleurs si vous voulez
je peux vous organiser quelque chose bon
sens tant qu'on
lui demande que ce n'est pas nécessaire
d'aller sur le truc de il s'est trop
froid j'ai perdu mais il n'a pas besoin
de sens car c'est très bien si c'est
très drôle ouais ça peut passer mais là
c'est vulgaire mais c'est possible s'est
passé il ya pas besoin de ça j'ai tout
donné mais aussi josé il ya un propos il
n'est pas besoin d'être
parfait qu'est ce que tu dirais comme
ce que les développeurs ont importé dans
ton pays je sais pas moi c'est à toi
nous dire c'est qu'elle genre
d'exploitation
la déforestation la désertification et
mais le pire c'est c'est le père noël
vous avez
vous avez essayé nous c'est le pire de
tous le père noël le père noël
ça a été ça a été difficile à avaler ce
alors qu'il restait mille fois pire
l'exploitation du sous-sol le pétrole
tout ça
l'ingérence dans les affaires sociales
de la paix sociale de l'état nous c'est
là qu'on nous applaudit on peut pas dit
si cette base en fait les gens c'est
vrai qu'ils ont dit qu'on est dépendant
mais on est toujours dépendant fin du
but c'est lui qui décide pour nous et
qui décide ça c'est évident et citations
et plus le pire
que nous ayons fait
à la base vous dirigez c'est pas les
élections en fait
chez nous ces contenus familiale soit on
voit qu'ils ont peu d'illusions à porter
sur les élections n'obligeait nouveauté
pour avoir moi mais ça c'est positif
moi je pense qu'il faut que ton deux
trucs négatifs ok les européens vous
avez apporté la déforestation l'est
l'expression ordination de nos richesses
un autre truc
l'école
pas négatif
le quotidien vraiment banal la monnaie
ils ont posé des mois ouais ouais nous
allons poser la longue
ils ont imposé de français ils ont
imposé la monnaie mais le pire nous ont
imposé le père noël
[Musique]
donc la marque ailée non seulement
contente de sponsoriser mais ce qu'elle
aimerait ça vous offrir à chacun il
montre
ça fera déjà un souvenir au pire vous
avez deux cadrans blancs de deux cadres
anthracite
je
souffrais trop grande
et voilà les siens
deux mille autres
2000 euros quand on fait le calcul ça
fait environ un million trois cent mille
mais je peux m'occuper de wideband
phénomène de trois mois quatre mois
comme ça non
suivent elles arriveront
les gens achètent ces mondes vieux
minéraux
abobo même quelqu'un qui travaille peut
ne pas voir si heureux de voir la fin du
mois
je t'ai dit peut être que t'es pas les
issues
la bonne est au bon endroit tout ça
et on est dans le même mode quoi on
partage la même
je faisais vite
[Musique]
c'est un peu la solitude
ça me plaît mais bon
j'aime mon corps
d habitude tu vois
ça m'a beaucoup
avant ici est obligés sinon tu clames
clients inquiets de la monnaie
une grande lac des montagnes tu vois
tout est beau
ne suis pas à l'aise dieu veille sur toi
la mère fait encore être quand on
travaille ça que tu allais faire fête et
du vin tv line hameau c'est une marque
pompiers
telle fierté pour
moi je suis ici je ne suis même pas un
tiers en suisse ep le monde veut un
parti insiste vraiment saine et un pour
moi
voilà tu fait la fierté de la famille on
compte sur toi et bisous mais autre
vision des jeunes un bébé
vous échouez vous dira peut-être capable
vous était pas été chercher ce alors que
vous pourriez voir le monde entier
première chose qui fait si vous y
regardez ce que j'ai fait ici tout le
monde que c'est du poison de l'emploi
jeune âge en plus de
viser mais pas les réseaux sociaux et
jaune bonjour
est ce qu'il ya des choses spéciales
à voir avec toi est ce juste une entrée
l'entrée oui c'est normal cette hausse
est tous d'accord toi tu es avec un
micro main donc tu rentres avec parfait
donc on va faire on va répéter cette
séquence la rentrée du côté jardin moi
je vais faire laurent qui donc les juste
avant toi qui donne toutes les consignes
au public et qui t'a nonce d'accord ok
voilà et puis nous on va le suivre parce
que c'est vrai que jamais a dit monsieur
jour laisse juste avant le direct en
compagnie de gex
[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir
mais c'est beaucoup presima si beaucoup
besoin demain si beaucoup pour cet
accueil je suis que l'on te laisse je
viens de la côte d'ivoire pourtant avant
devenu c'est pas ce qu'on m'a dit on m'a
dit le public en suisse est très timide
par rapport au public en afrique et moi
je pense qu'on ne doit pas vous jeter la
pierre parce qu'on rit plus fois en
afrique en suisse parce qu'on afrique on
n'est pas vraiment dans un appartement
sur de rythme et a donc c'est le moment
où on donne tout alors qu'en suisse ça
va vous devez connaître encore de bons
moments ça va et puis vous les européens
quand vous entendez parler de l'afrique
automatiquement vos pensées au viol au
partage au sous développement mais
laissez-moi vous dire aujourd'hui que
toutes ces idées que vous faites de
l'afrique et bien c'est vrai ça fait
plus de deux jours que je découvre la
sucent je vous ai bien observer
pardon mais en fait la suisse j'aime pas
trop boutons c'est vrai que depuis tout
petit en un seul rêve chez nous mais ni
chez les blancs juste après celui de
devenir blanc bien sûr
mais c'est bon j'ai changé d'avis la
suisse est trop classe tout est parfait
je dirais même trop à faire pour un seul
et même pays normalement moi je devais
fait qu'un jeu ici je viens de faire
deux allez ça va c'est bon pour moi et
si d'ailleurs il ya des gens dans la
salle que veut venir avec moi de mettre
de couvrir mon quartier ça va je vous
paie le transport on m'a dit vous étiez
combien dans la salle déjà 1700 c'est
bon ça fait rentrer j'ai un ami qui
s'appelle mamadou sy l'habitat pour
lancer un malien il a une petite
embarcation très sympa et en plus ce
qu'il a l'habitude de 20 euros le voyage
retour à vide donc c'est sûr qu'il va
enfin bon prix allez merci beaucoup de
m'avoir écouté ses des plantes et
lettres
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
beaucoup
qu'est ce que je pourrais à chute
elle s'en fout
la partie ouais pourquoi pas vous
si je comprends bien céder phone
grâce à l'humidité ça va diffuser une
intensité du gaz la plaque électrique
est toujours commencé avec la conduite
d'hollywood et soignons blanc avec des
tomates et faire des choses en sauce
swing style tajine au style ratatouille
et jacub combien la celui ci il est à 79
donc c'est super plus tôt plus vous
allez cuisiner avec les plus savas
culotté en fait ça va être ça va être
bon tout les flaques vous allez dire ça
fait des vrais plats comme avant
juste comme ses shows pas d'eau froide
aussi pas de choc thermique
et puis et puis vraiment après on a des
choses qui sont moins chers sur le m
quand j'arrivais saladier
il ya des coupables il ya des plats
d'espèces de placement salade ou manger
des céréales faire un musée le matin de
bosnie ont fait un déjeuner salade
individuelle et ça ça promet ceux ci
sont un vin se s'il voyait le prix
prendre
et 21 les formats blocs avec
je crois qu'on voulait mettre combien
votre avis
3 quand même deux ou trois s'agit pas de
3 c'est à dire moi je comprends pas
combien d'argent a way home animaux
n'est
pas la meilleure tactique donnée la
négation de négoce ont négocié c'est
très silencieux et c'est pourquoi j'ai
fait c'est pas grave ma g roupe aux
genevois
n'auront pas de cadeau ça va
être avec tout le monde et moi j'aime
pratiquer
je ne
sais pas
[Musique]
il faut qu'ils sentent quand on regarde
thales
ce que c'est ça tu communiques quelque
chose tu communiques des émotions au
public si tu arrives tu restes tu vois
les stresser
c'est arrivé très content qu'on soir me
déstresser tu laisses tu sois est resté
je te rassure je te rassure tu seras se
passer deux minutes avant de monter sur
scène
l'étang de premières secondes tu seras
peut-être pas prêt
on attend toujours le père noël chez
nous avec impatience oui mais pas pour
les mêmes raisons que vous non on se
disait qu'il allait fini par venir et
joue avec ses rennes oui drm chez nous
on appelle ça vienne de brousse on
attend pour mettre les rênes de la sauce
qu'il dit nous c'est trop beau
chez nous on mange tous les animaux même
le joint euro les chiffres même les
chats
ah ouais
les banques lui menti
pas
[Musique]
où
et
il
[Musique]
du sud obligé de faire italie cet
empêchement
[Musique]
je me dis ça va tu le fais tu peux me
fais pas écouté
[Applaudissements]
l'histoire soit
[Musique]
amis
c'est le seul endroit où j'arrive à
faire ce que vous
[Musique]
et ce soit
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
comment avoir été de démontrer
vous nous avez imposé le français nous
avait imposé la monnaie est le pays
le père noël
[Musique]
on
c'est une bonne manière s'appelle prague
où il habite à plomb il a une petite en
paca compterait et loire
et en plus ce qu'il a l'habitude de
paleron le voyage de la vie d'un sigle
enfin robin ainsi tous ses charmes
c'est cadeau
massi montre de membres vous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le cours du baril fils grave au palais
tout crédit c'est ça cartonne ces poids
[Musique]
c'était génial mais super mais ce n'est
pas vrai qu'à une continuation messieurs
1re présenter ça c'est vrai précieux
[Musique]
et
c'est une belle expérience j'ai appris
beaucoup de choses j'ai fait des
connaissances
ça me donne envie de remonter sur scène
de européenne parce que je vous ferais
tu vois déjà rodé mais je me dis que je
dois mieux mais préparés ici essayer de
mieux coopérer le plus d'abidjan décousu
voire d'afrique
mon corps mon esprit n'est pas encore
prêt à accepter ce qui se passe là bas
c'est à dire la température le nouveau
devis tout ça je suis pas encore prêt à
ce qui arrive en suisse tu vois ainsi à
peine les gens n'ont pas le temps les
gens ont pensé que ça allait au travail
tout seul on va travailler ça va
peut-être parce qu'on n'a pas de boulot
mais on a le cacao en alu café et on a
le sens de l'humour
tout le monde a le sens de nous ici
[Applaudissements]
moi ça me plaît
m
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
il
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà pour ce document de noémie mayodon
et jean charles richard que vous pouvez
retrouver en replay ainsi que tous nos
reportages sur le site france24 à la
rubrique émissions et reporter c'est la
fin de ce magazine merci de l'avoir
suivi on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine sur france ô
[Musique]